groupe Union centriste pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
avant de voter sur l'année le Mans sur
la partie recette de ce premier budget
de la législature je voudrais revenir un
instant sur les grandes orientations
qu'il fixent et sur les points de
vigilance du groupe Union centriste nous
avons consacré les précédentes lois de
finances initiale et loi de finances
rectificatives au sauvetage de notre
économie face à la crise sanitaire et
l'examen de ce projet de budget pour
2023 a débuté au lendemain de l'adoption
par notre Haute Assemblée d'un second
collectif budgétaire 2022 lui-même
destiné à protéger les Français face aux
dangers qui que font peser l'ensemble de
l'inflation élevée et la guerre en
Ukraine et les aléas climatiques
dépenses dépassant de beaucoup la
conjoncture immédiate la succession de
ces crises mais lourdement a
contribution nos finances publiques
or le resserrement de la politique
monétaire amorcée par la Banque centrale
européenne pour juguler l'inflation
change inéluctablement la donne
budgétaire dans ces conditions certes
nouvelles mais néanmoins attendues les
membres du groupe Union centrisme ont
abordé abordé ce projet de budget 2023
dans un esprit de responsabilité fidèle
à notre ligne constructive nous avons
été forces de proposition oui nous
devons collectivement concourir
redressement des comptes publics afin de
conserver la maîtrise de notre destin
notre groupe juge néanmoins impératif
d'associer à la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques l'optimisation des rentrées
fiscales dans les caisses de l'état
en votant la suppression de l'article 5
nous avons voté le maintien pour l'année
2023 de 4 milliards d'euros de CVAE
aujourd'hui perçus par le bloc communal
et les départements l'objectif affiché
n'est pas seulement de préserver
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
locales il est aussi de sauvegarder les
substantiels ressources publiques dont
on ne peut se priver pour financer les
soutiens exceptionnels aux entreprises
nous avons également concrétisé dans ce
projet de budget plusieurs propositions
volontaristes visant à rationaliser
notre système fiscal dans un double
souci d'efficacité économique et
d'équité sociale
le remplacement de l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière par un impôt sur la
fortune improductive je songe aussi à la
suppression d'une niche fiscale
implicite sur la transmission du
patrimoine des plus fortunés qui
contourne l'impôt sur le revenu en
exploitant une faille du nouveau plan
d'épargne retraite
issue de la loi pacte en faisant adopter
notre amendement nous avons corrigé une
anomalie qui se chiffrerait d'après
certaines à plusieurs plusieurs
milliards mais qui n'est pas évalué dans
l'article d'équilibre qui nous a été
présenté nous nous réjouissons par
ailleurs d'être parvenus avec le
concours et l'aval du rapporteur général
de la commission des finances à
améliorer et renforcer le dispositif de
filets de sécurité en faveur des
collectivités territoriales monsieur le
ministre les élus du bloc communal
confrontés à l'explosion de leurs
dépenses d'approvisionnement en énergie
ont besoin d'une réponse claire lisible
et rapide
nous espérons vivement que le dispositif
adopté par le Sénat survivra aux 49.3
voilà un balayage nécessaire rapide et
non exhaustif des apports du Sénat et de
notre groupe que nous voulions mettre en
valeur avant le votre solennelle qui
aura lieu dans quelques minutes monsieur
le ministre je vous ai entendu il y a
quelques instants nous a signé une
trajectoire d'économie pour la seconde
partie du budget je vais tout de même
vous rappeler que nous venons depuis
huit jours de vous proposer des
milliards de recettes supplémentaires et
des milliards de suppressions de
dépenses fiscales parce qu'elle ne vous
conviennent pas vous les ignorez le
groupe Union centriste est allé bien
au-delà du redressement attendu et je
vous prierai de l'entendre bien
évidemment nous regrettons de ne pas
avoir pu élargir la contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité à
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activités
économiques au-delà du seul secteur de
l'énergie
il demeure inacceptable de taxer
certains sans limites particulièrement
ceux qui ont besoin de ressources pour
réussir leur transition écologique quand
d'autres non concernés continuent
d'accumuler des profits records c'est
obstination a instauré des privilèges
dans un contexte de déficit public bien
trop excessif engage la responsabilité
du gouvernement mais 2023 ne nous a
encore pas tout dit et peut-être que
nous n'aurons plus le choix dans
quelques mois quoi qu'il en soit mes
chers collègues le groupe Union
centriste salue la qualité des échanges
que nous avons eu dans cette hémicycle
et continuera à être force de
proposition pour la suite de l'examen du
PLF nous voterons en faveur de la
première partie du projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 je vous remercie
merci chers collègues j'appelle la
présente Monsieur Christian Billac pour
le groupe RDSE vous avez 5 minutes